you know everybody talks about what is
the key to success you know the key to
success is marry the right person save
money work hard go to school get a
degree love people faith God uh you hear
so many different things and we were
having this debate one time
uh and I would ask everybody it's just
the basic question everybody what's the
key to success I'm like you know what
years later I said I in my mind the
biggest key to success almost anybody I
see that takes it to whole different
level the highest levels the difference
between them and other people is their
sequencing
and what I mean by sequencing is the
following so you and I may have the same
vision of what we want to do in life
okay you want to get here I want to get
here this could be anything we both want
to build a billion dollar company fine
we both want to be building a company
that does 100 million a year we both
want to go into uh football we both want
to go play at the highest level we both
want to go out there and be great sales
whatever maybe that's the ultimate right
if my order of steps I take to go here
isn't as efficient as yours because your
sequencing is better you're going to get
there faster than I am and I may not
even never even get there because I'm
trying to do move 14 on move three and
that's the most common thing that you
see one day I woke up
I was in a relationship and this is I'm
26 years old 27 years old 26 25 years
old and I'm trying to get my business
going I wake up six o'clock in the
morning
I get a text
babe I have to tell you this as much as
I love you I don't see this relationship
going anywhere one of those texts
because I think my mom is right you love
your business more than you love me and
I barely see you I only see you once a
week you're working so hard first text
then message I press the message to
listen to it my mom
you know there used to be a time they
used to love me and you would call me
and tell me you love me what happened to
those what happened to my little son
that used to love his mother every day
yeah
so so now I got a breakup on the line I
got a guilt trip from my mom that's
still 602 right now then I get in you
haven't got out of bed yet I haven't
even gotten out of bed yet then I get an
email
it's been in the uh a box for a while
and I look at it it's from my number one
client that I was about to expect like a
fifteen thousand dollar commission and
that's a lot of money at that time and
my number one client says he's leaving
me for the following reasons and then at
the same time the next email is my agent
saying I resign my number one agent
presents this all happens before 605
610. so I'm in bed anxiety's High Panic
is high I have no idea what to do in
that moment all I thought about is what
are my next five moves what do I need to
do next from that moment on everything I
did with business I would ask myself I'm
gonna do this next my next 10 15 moves
what would this guy do this guy that
built an Empire what would he do what
are we going to do here what can I do to
be better than this guy what can I do to
be more efficient and what can I do to
speed up the process to get you but
everything came down to your next five
moves so you're asking the questions the
first move the most important absolutely
it is if you don't know your next move
your next move can hurt their chances of
you even getting to the fifth move yeah
so it's always your next point it
matters the most what is the next move
that everyone should be thinking about
so the first thing you have to do is you
gotta last night I'm at rafi's place and
I'm having dinner with my three buddies
none of us are supposed to do anything
alive one of them is Stephen affo
they're running a 300 billion dollar
your business Steve was the Michael
Jordan of our high school okay he's a
great basketball player but we're all
2.0 GPA kids right and our moans is
great salesman yes 2.0 yes yes and
Armond was always a fighter he would
always get in trouble like he was a guy
that he's the five six guy you don't
want to fight like you'd go to a party
you know the smallest guy go to a party
and this five six guy would go to a
party and he would stand there and he
would say that guy's looking at me I'm
like bro he's not looking at you no I
know he's looking at me he's looking I'm
like I promise you he's not looking he's
the kind of guy that would walk up and
just punch the guy in the face just for
no reason just for no reason what is the
matter with you right that's his wiring
yeah but we're all together yesterday
now we all have kids we have two three
and Armand has four kids we're Center
we're talking Arman runs rafi's place if
you've been to rafi's place the
restaurant and Glenda if you've not been
you've got to go it's the best middle
middle eastern restaurant we're just
we're sitting there yesterday and we're
having all these conversations
challenges men go through whether it's
marriage money Health what happens at
41. oh everything that you don't want to
talk publicly that men are insecure
about we just talk about it right there
right collectively
and the biggest thing that I talk about
with one of my friends yesterday is
listen your number one move is you
identifying who you want to be not not
who Tiffany wants to be not who it's who
do you want to be not not what Patrick
wants to be not what Bobby wants not
what your older brother sister mom that
who do you want to be if you and I can
figure out who we want to be and it's as
transparent and as clear as possible I
don't have to compare myself against
your success now here's a problem though
say for instance I sit there and I say
honestly I just want to be a person
that's just a regular person and I'm
glad if I make 80 grand a year 100 Grand
a year I have a nice place I'm married
I'm happy my kids are with me I have
good relationships I'm totally happy
if you say that if that's what you want
to be if you say that's what you want to
be but if you say I want something else
and you're not doing it then what
exactly but watch this one if you say
that's what you want to be and you're
content with that life
but behind closed doors your buddy Lewis
Howes
is making millions he's doing great he's
all over the place people are talking
about it if an ounce of Envy or jealousy
comes in you either weren't being honest
with yourself because that's not exactly
who you wanted to be or you got to ask
the decision am I living my life or his
life that's the toughest thing to do
right toughest thing to know the other
side of it is that let's just say you
got a big upside you know in sports a
lot of times you know Stephen A Smith
did an interview the other day and they
asked him about Vince Carter and it was
the toughest question what that was
asked they said so Vince Carter he just
announced 23 years of retirement he's
leaving the NBA Stephen A what can you
say about Vince Carter's legacy okay now
I don't know if you guys know Vince
Carter is this guy dumped over to seven
footer in the Olympics the guy retired
afterwards
with the elbow sick what he was doing in
Toronto McGrady it's just beautiful when
you watch this guy play I remember one
time he dropped 50 in the playoffs you
thought this guy's going to win the
Championships and he came from Target
Wheels North Carolina is going to be the
next mic but here's what Stephen A said
about Vince Carter very difficult
he said he's you know how Stephen he
doesn't stand he's kind of like you know
and you know he typically is quick to
give the answer one second goes by two
seconds goes by five second goes by he
still hasn't said a word then all of a
sudden he says
well I got to tell you this is a good
brother I love this man he's a great man
you know he goes into building him up
and then he says but it is the most
unfulfilled Talent we've ever seen in
the history of the NBA really he says
this man should have been competing with
the Kobe's of the world the LeBrons of
the world the Jordans of the world but
we never saw it
I wish I would have seen the best of
them and you it's like a minute and 13
seconds it's so awkward
if Vince Carter watches that and it
doesn't bother him
more more power to you because you were
happy to be in the NBA and you were cool
with that but if you bought watch that
and it bothers you you know deep down I
said he could have done more so you as
the individual have to make a decision
either I'm going for all the I want all
the marbles and I'm willing to go be
embarrassed lose public humiliation
after another one after until I get
there or I'm going to live a simple life
and I'm okay with this well you have to
be clear about that that's step number
one okay what's step two once you once
you're identifying that part then it's
figuring out your own talents that you
have and once I know my talents where
can my talents be used you know if
you're a numbers guy what industry can
use your talents well maybe it's Finance
economy investment banker you know maybe
it's on that's it if it's a creative
side maybe I'm gonna go be on the
marketing side maybe I want to be behind
the scenes I don't want to be in front
of camera I want to be the support
person then you say well I'm not a good
number one guy I'm a good number two
person I'm a number three person then
you have to find out your positioning at
the point at the point of your life Tom
was the former president of our company
PHP uh one of the best decisions was
hiring this guy when I hired Tom and
brought him on board he introduced me to
vistage years ago this is just kind of
like a YPO you're familiar with white
people so vistages an element of that
it's very similar but it's a little bit
older crowd why people's a little bit
younger Vista just 560 year olds right
and I want to be around 60 year old so
introduce me to vistage
and over the years we became very good
friends before I hired them
and I said so Tom let me ask you a
question in your life you you guys so
jammed that for 780 million you got a
massive exit but you were the number six
guy
how come you don't want to be the number
one guy he says good question he gave me
the best answer he says you realize I'm
54 years old at the time we were talking
he says it took me 54 years to realize
I'm not a good number one
54 years 54 years to realize I'm not a
good number one what would have happened
if you realize that at 30. that's the
point every one of his biggest checks he
ever got he was a number five the number
four or the number every time he was
number one the company didn't do well so
sometimes we want to be number one but
maybe you're not a number one sometimes
you want to be MJ but maybe you're
Scotty sometimes you want to be mg and
Scotty but maybe you're John Paxton and
Steve Kerr maybe you're somebody that
later on is going to be the general
manager of the you know Chicago Bulls
your name is John Paxson maybe you're
going to be a great coach yours later
winning three out of five championships
your name is Steve Kerr but you got to
play your game with your strength so one
end of the season of life exactly and in
the seasonal life because you may be a
number six right now but you may
eventually be a good number one maybe
it's just a different role in a
different package yes but it's the
sequencing man everything is sequencing
what is sequencing mean for you is that
sequencing to me means okay you if you
wake up every day you have a sequence of
what you do okay like what's the first
thing you do when you wake up mostly
meditate okay what's the next thing you
do make my bed and then what's the next
thing you do brush my teeth shower okay
that's a sequence okay so that now what
if I wake up and the first thing I do is
I shower first okay then I go eat then I
put my clothes on then I go to work and
I say sometime throughout the day I'm
going to meditate I just mess the whole
sequence up what is the foundation of
what I'm starting the day with right
yeah what is the sequence of what I'm
going to be doing next if every decision
you're about to make next whether it's
marriage having kids Business
Partnership a joint venture if
everything you did you stepped away from
the world your girl your mom your dad
your peers your family you went to a
restaurant you sat there with a piece of
paper saying okay
I'm thinking about marriage what do I
need to do next what's the next move I
need to make then you go I don't know if
that's number one I think that's number
three and you play that game it's
fascinating right it's fascinating it's
like playing chess it's like you know
these Master chess players they know
their next 10 to 50 moves the amateurs
were like uh here we go this is what I'm
gonna do you know and these guys are
like
yeah yeah what are you doing yeah
they'll see it in the future it's called
sequencing but it takes the steps to get
to the Future you can't just jump to the
future I mean it's the story of Bob
iger's the story of uh Ted Turner's the
story of Kirk accordion you know how a
Kirk accordion went from being a regular
guy in Bakersfield who didn't graduate
past eighth grade you know goes and pays
a guy a dollar to let him fly a plane
and eventually becomes a pilot for Bugsy
with the mob and eventually goes and
becomes a pilot buys TWA turns it into a
big company sells it for a few hundred
million dollars then decides to go to
Vegas then he decides to buy a couple
hotels then he buys 80 acres of property
across the street from Tropicana then he
buys MGM he's not the founder of MGM he
turns it into what it is dies at 98
years old as a multi-billion it gives a
billion dollars to Armenia after the
earthquake of 1988 this is all
sequencing man this is all sequencing
when you go through it everything is
sequencing yeah and when you look at it
that way you tend to make better
decisions
foreign
[Music]